so you're preparing to launch a
crowdfunding campaign yes in February
march two to give us a nice little
production budget for season two laps so
what's some of your prep work that
you're doing it's going to be a lot of
biggest thing is like trying to figure
out what are these rewards you know
that's such a big thing because that's
that's a the thing that's enticing
people to donate you know what are they
getting out of it and i'm actually i'm
gearing i'm compiling a list but i'll
have like a set list yet of things some
of them are like we did a commentary for
season one that i never released so and
it's when it's honestly so long ago that
i don't remember doing this remember me
r me yes me and art hall who is not here
right now in the next time I America
station I'm actually rachet in a mask ya
know what I gotten away with it too yeah
alright so yeah we all set around we all
SAT around we Matt Lewis was there when
we record this ad rachets apartment
you're right up y'all crowd there's a
line you know what a probable i
guarantee actually the were usually
whatever projects article was also
whenever i do commentary that's usually
out using or share a crack of a beer can
or overtime yeah it's miller time she
knows me yeah so we so that is what we
did that and i'd like to put that out as
like a one of the rewards cuz it's
really funny it's probably i'm gonna get
maybe it's just funny to us but no I'm
just kidding no t-shirts you're not
doing I would like to tell your change
doing t-shirts yeah because this is a
good idea to show such a workout you
know like going to the track kind of
thing would be cool to have like a tank
top or something you know not fanny pack
fanny pack right to keep
the phone and the cigarettes yeah
exactly all the things you need when you
were to cash you need the wide one for
the cigars right yeah a little hip
humidor yeah um that's a good idea
though task well may my flask maybe we
could have dvds or the first season yeah
you know the volvo knows feature them
you know so the audition tapes I think
is mmm interesting he doesn't like no
one likes audition tapes okay all right
I don't look at no actors like well
maybe some actors like their own
audition tapes and if they do very well
haha a little leery about that so yeah
I'm getting that stuff together and then
I in a couple weeks we're gonna shoot
the poem like the the pitch video oh
great okay and are you having everybody
involved and yeah you'll narrator uh
I'll probably sort of like the video
journal intro it but um we'll shoot it
back at the track and I'd like to have
all the roles cast by then so that we
can have the entire cast there and just
be like you know this is what we're this
is our team of actors and talent that
the are going to bring season 2 to life
kind of thing and then ask for money are
you doing research on what campaign
videos look sort of yes strike a chord
in you yeah like me how'd you have any
examples of you know I am I was a great
campaign video I'm I jocelyn towne yeah
she did agree yeah and there was also uh
why I do like um um God what's that guy
that we were just talking about the
feature film that he's been working on
for all the guy from no no photo yeah
who did such an amazing
with this video absolutely i mean the
tricks that he used that video was
really cool I don't know what I'm gonna
pull that but you know yeah really
there's a hitch and that's what this is
going to come down to is do you have a
compelling pitch and yeah i'm looking at
other campaigns and it's not like i'm
using just one for like an example i'm
looking at several and then I taken
piece by piece and making notes kind of
thing so i wish i had more examples but
it's more just as I go my oh that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool and I
tuck it away and then how have you
determined how much you're going to ask
for one thing you've seen recently is
that people really going for these high
amounts right and it's been it's been
harder these days to get them i think
people are the honeymoon periods kind of
over for crowdfunding i think it's a
little tougher right and there's also a
huge debate between indy gogo and
Kickstarter which I'm still debating
okay yeah but i'm gonna i'm going to
keep it low you know I know that I can
fall back on some you know my own
personal money but also some friends
here in la that have camera equipment
that i would like to you know they've
already said yeah you going to use it so
I'm keeping the budget low it's mostly
for locations because it's such a bigger
story yeah yeah the locations are that's
going to be a big piece of it now I want
to go to have the money for food and
whatever you know lighting is a big
thing to sew arts place that's true we
go if there's a way to fake it into a
two bedroom apartment absolutely i'm
open to it I I happy I've did very humid
sure these apartments I've lived in I've
always allowed people to film it and
like I'm like oh sure of course halfway
through my damn it why did I say yes to
this because it you know it's a little
whirling dervish comes into your
apartment everything just gets all over
but of course now we'll make it work you
know but yeah the world is much bigger
but I think it's gonna bit strongly
benefit us yeah so I'm not going to
shoot for them
for a hundred-thousand-dollar of IG I'm
going for like a 3500 and give you a
pretty modest it's really modest for
what why made season 1 on lane 20 bucks
maybe let's craft services yeah yeah
like however much bottled and I want
doughnuts yeah you didn't talk about
taco every talk about tacos and lots of
starches and carbs which is perfect for
someone is trying to lose weekend thank
you good and then you're not planning on
going on any vacations or anything
during the campaign talking to another
girl you know okay no weddings or
anything no I'm just gonna me i'm going
to vegas for a couple days in the april
but that's pretty much it no yeah okay
i'm gonna be okay i guess i was going to
tweet I rather tweeted she knelt waiting
around Vegas oh well so the picture of
me at Caesars yeah circus circus i think
has good wife eyes yeah well you're the
healthy network that's true we do
husband right we have plans so what else
have you noticed from crowdfunding
campaigns that you like what are some of
the things that you've seen that it
really worked and then someone happened
the over budget I feel like a big one
but not having a good pitch video to me
I feel like is the ones I've seen I'm
like and I would never donate to that
because the video wasn't good whether it
was a production value or just the pitch
wasn't good I just didn't feel like it
was a compelling on a story or you know
that kind of stuff so I really want to
make sure I'm good with that do you
think people view that as okay if the
pitch video is bad then what's the
actual production won't look like
possesses some representation of their
work hmm well I mean that's a way I take
it I don't feel that just the pitch
video is enough I feel that people are
buying not just a reward like a DVD or
t-shirt or a chance for a sign script or
something they're they're trying to
become a part of a process that they
normally wouldn't be so invite them
along with that journey like you know
show them where are you coming from
where you want to go like the good
things the bad things that happen so
keep them in the loop and that's what
I've seen all the successful ones I'm
only followed one or two
Ray Lewis I hard labor looked like I
know one of them was um kind of an easy
sell forgot the guy's name but he was
one of these video game developers in
the 90s who did a lot of point-and-click
adventures like day of the tentacle and
stuff like that and he wanted to make a
throwback point click game for all the
people who reminisce like me and all
those other people when he said a
hundred thousand dollars when I need to
fully design an engineer and develop
this program and he would make videos if
not weekly than daily to talk about
progress and all the artwork and
everything he made three or four hundred
thousand dollars because people were so
on board with you know that part of it
is again the subject matter of you know
you're playing on the nostalgia of the
game you know culture from that era but
he took you on a ride and showed you how
did things work and that I think is
really the big that's why it's you need
a marketing team or someone full time
because takes a lot to consistently
update and send messages and video and
then edit and all that stuff yeah that's
what I think is really the big indicator
or big thing to help and for me the
video journals is trying to do that
mm-hmm do you think you'll do a shorter
campaign 30 days or longer um I'm I'm
right now I'm on 30 yeah what makes you
like that date that 30 day uh-huh I
don't it's a good number yeah it's just
a month and you try it out if it the
other thing too is I know that there's
the the chance failure you don't make it
in very days you know so then we need to
do another campaign or 30 fall back
instead of putting it all in one 60-day
campaign against yeah yeah because I'm
I'm not doing this campaign to be like
I'm gonna you know please donate and we
might shoot in a year it's like I'm
doing this campaign please donate we're
shooting in May you know we're ready to
go well you're not gonna be able to
sleep it's not exactly I don't you I
mean yeah you like to do things yeah
what and that's great I like to have
things ready like I didn't start I
didn't start trying I didn't try to cast
lap season one
without the script being in a good place
you know I feel like you need to have
confidence in you know someone's going
to come onto your team you got to have a
basis you know you gotta have that that
thing is that's going to motivate people
would be like no I want to work on that
and if and that requires me to have my
stuff in line I have it in check and
ready you know
you